hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torkelt wir machen heute eine
resteverwertung und zwar wird es eine
ganz gruselig resteverwertung
denn wir haben heute kekse gebacken und
da haben wir nur geld gebraucht schnitt
haben wir ganz viel eiweiß übrig und aus
diesem eiweiß kann man jetzt entweder
zum beispiel eine pablo warthe machen
wie ich sie schon mal gemacht habe
die ist unglaublich lecker und die
solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren
das rezept verlinke ich euch hier oder
ihr könnt kleine pc stückchen machen und
da haben wir uns jetzt etwas inspirieren
lassen von der zeitschrift und werden
heute passend zu halloween ein paar
gruselige geister machen und zu mir und
ich wir zeigen euch jetzt gleich mal die
wenigen zutaten und zeigen euch dann wie
es gleich weitergeht
wir haben hier drei weisen als 150 super
und man rechnet pro 150 gramm zucker
deswegen ist es egal wie viel übrig habt
einfach pro 150 gramm zucker nehmen
dann legen wir noch und telefon spalt
stärke und eine prise salz die hilfe
nämlich dass die eiweißstrukturen
schneller zerstört wird
jetzt geben wir zuerst das eiweiß mit
dem salz in die rührschüssel und lassen
es so lange verrühren bis das eiweiß
steif ist und stand kommt nach und nach
der zucker mit rein und dann müssen wir
diese mischung etwa noch vier minuten
rühren bis sich der zucker darin
aufgelöst hat zum schluss sollte so eine
feste bc masse entstanden sein und dann
können wir uns die speisestärke
unterheben und dann ist diese baiser
masse auch schon bereit zum spritzen
jetzt habe ich ihn einen spritzbeutel
mit einer schule mit war ganz großen und
stehen stecke ich hier in meiner
pölten ständer so habe ich nämlich beide
hände frei und kann jetzt diese wm ab
mit dem spritzbeutel dann auf spricht
jetzt nehme ich einfach so eine
zweitkarte und schiebt es alles nach
vorne
dann mach ich mir nämlich da hinten die
hände nicht dreckig jetzt werde gedreht
fast immer vorne
und jetzt könnt ihr entweder diese
baiser massa direkt auf dem backpapier
spritzen einfach so kreisrund oder
englisch als hilfe und das finde ich
jetzt besonders gut diese opladen
sie gibt es ja aufs ganze jahr zu kaufen
das netz liefern küche und es sind sogar
ihr opladen und opladen kennt man ja
eigentlich aus der weihnachtsbäckerei
aber die gibt es eben auch das ganze ja
man kann nicht nur hier wieder abgegeben
hat muss makronen oder kokosmakronen
machen sondern man kann eben zum
beispiel auch das benutzen um diese böse
geister zu machen dass ich nehms s
papier welches auf den tisch es auch
gehabt jetzt nehme ich mir eine oblate
und habe deswegen schon einen schönen
runden kreis kam aus auf und kann jetzt
von außen anfangen und dann in der mitte
einmal
meine oblaten haben übrigens einen
durchmesser von 50 mm als 5 cm und die
gibt es aber auch in kleinen serien 40
mm zum beispiel
duisburg auf www einfach war es nicht
schwer okay und rebecca sind jetzt
fertig aufgespritzt und so dürfen sie
jetzt auf dem blech im ofen trocknet
ich wollte das jetzt mal um luft machen
bei 70 grad und da brauchen sie etwa 90
minuten
falls ihr keinen um das backofen habt
könnt ihr auch einfach ober und
unterhitze nehmen
dann nimmt die etwa 90 grad und daneben
auch 90 minuten
ihr erkennt auch ob die bc kaska fertig
getrocknet sind wenn ihr einfach mal
drauf klopft uns hat sich wohl an und
wir lassen sie jetzt trocken und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder das bauamt
und machten so sehen sind unsere
begeister aus und sandra markert noch
ein paar augen drauf und zwar nehmen wir
einfach diese passten farbe ist nämlich
ab sofort frei und stil komme einfach
mit einem pinsel auf malle
wir haben uns hier einfach einen kleinen
farbtupfer drauf gegeben die farben sind
total erheblich jetzt kann man hier
einfach die farbe mit einem pinsel
auftragen entweder nur zwei augen
verwirrt bei mir oder gleich ein ganzes
gesicht wie bei hier ab
so sehen dann die fertigen geister aus
wir hoffen dass sich dieses rezept
gefallen hat und diese kleine grusel
idee und verlierer und ich werde jetzt
noch ein paar anderen leckereien backen
und heute ok power dieses rezept gibt es
natürlich zum nachlesen aufstocken
welt.de
ich freue mich darüber wenn ihr dieses
rezept man nach macht oder wenn ihr auch
diese paulo warte mal ausprobiert die
ist nämlich so lecker ich glaube die
mache ich demnächst auch mal wieder
wieso denn ganz gleich ob es dort mit da
können sie auch gucken und wir sehen uns
dann einfach vom nächsten mal wieder bis
bald ein festkleid auf affen können
super
und wie heißt mein neuer blog blog de
hält nie ganz